all right question for you
what do you want your legacy
to be that's the question of the day
revolving
around legacy now
on today's episode of sas talks money
we're going to be talking about the
legacy
of the late great kobe bryant today is
the one
year anniversary of kobe bryant's
tragic death in the helicopter accident
that took
him and eight other people's lives nine
people lost their lives
that day now the question regarding
legacy do you have something in mind of
what you want your legacy to be and you
might be asking
well what does legacy have to do with
money and what does legacy have to do
with personal finance that's my
expertise personal finance
well the answer is as it turns out
everything legacy has everything
to do with personal finance so i've
developed something called
the six principles of wealth or the size
six
as some people call it and in these six
principles of wealth
i basically uncovered that you don't
need to
read 50 different books or take 100
different personal finance classes to
understand money
you really have to be great at these six
things so i started asking financial
advisors
planners estate planners just
understanding about money that's how
this show
started and i basically found out there
are these six things and number six
is what is called chilling chilling is
when you own your time chilling is what
you can do whatever you want
with your free time so that's all about
child so when i ask people yo what's
your chilling
what's your chillin most people have the
same
three or four responses they want to
travel
they want to pursue a passion and they
want to donate their time and give back
to
causes they care about and the greats
the greats
they would like to leave a legacy that's
what being chilling is all about owning
your time if you had millions of dollars
in the bank
you didn't have to get up and rush to
work or do anything what would your
chilling be
and that's what this episode is all
about leaving
a legacy so on today's episode of sales
talks money we're going to talk about
the legacy of kobe bryant but also
help you find out what you want your
legacy
to be let's
all right so on today's episode we're
going to be covering three
topics three topics we're gonna be
getting into
number one my story like how i even
ended up
filming this episode on a beach right
now in sunny south florida
that's number one number two
the mamba mentality the mentality that
that kept kobe bryant driven
in doing what he wanted to do and number
three as we discussed earlier
legacy okay so let's get into my story
like how did i end up on this beach
today
let me tell you let's rewind one year
exactly we're going to go back
one year in time and i am going to be
very real with you guys right now this
is probably the realest
episode i've done on valuetainment
so one year ago i was in a very
dark place in my life i was 39 years old
my beautiful girlfriend she was 24 at
the time
uh was diagnosed with cancer with
leukemia heartbreaking
and that messed me up big time
right after that happened my father
passed away now we had a very
topsy-turvy relationship we actually
weren't even speaking at the time
and i lost my father so my girlfriend
who i'm madly in love with has cancer
my father who i've got this crazy
relationship with
passes and oh i'm about to turn 40
and i'm questioning everything in my
life
what the hell is going on why is this
happening to me why is this happening to
the people around me
like what the is happening right
now and for someone if you know me at
all i'm a very
positive joking around friends with
everyone kind of a guy
and i was in a complete dark place
something that i've never really
been in in my life and um
this was late january obviously a year
ago
and patrick beck david shows up to town
in south florida so i'm from miami and
pat
we'll let until the motorcycle passes
and pat shows up and he says let's meet
up and i said man
i would love to meet up i am really
hurting right now
and i meet up with pat i remember the
day
and i take an uber because i don't have
a car and i take an uber to fort
lauderdale and i meet him mario our
buddy paul
at a cafe in fort lauderdale and he says
what's up man
and i'm basically like look i'm i'm not
in a good place right now
and i'm really looking for a little bit
more of a purpose
to what i'm doing i have my career in
financial sales it's going great i made
a ton of money
i have this project i'm working on sas
talks money
it's all about helping millennials in
gen z understand
money and breaking it down in a language
they can understand
and i'm just a little lost right now and
he's like dude
i got you why don't you come team up
with me he was in dallas
come move to dallas be a part of what
we're doing
and just kind of be part of the
valuetainment team i had known pat for
eight years at that point
and i was like wow uh that sounds
awesome man uh i'm excited let's let's
work this out
so that was at the beginning of the week
so i started telling my friends
yo man like i don't know if you know
about this guy pat and valuetainment
it's sick best youtube channel business
entrepreneurship
crazy interviews interviewing like the
best of the best of the best
they interviewed george w bush he
interviewed the mafia guys and
did you see his interview with kobe
bryant that's what i would tell people
you gotta watch
his interview with kobe bryant if you
want to understand what valuetainment is
about
and what pat is all about so i started
telling people
about this kobe bryant interview i kid
you not
three days later uh kobe dies
in that tragic helicopter accident oh
and to make the story
even crazier the day that i met pat he
literally pulled up on an elevator
on a helicopter he got off a helicopter
i met him for lunch
and it was like this
crazy turn of events where
my girlfriend gets cancer my dad passes
i'm questioning my entire existence i'm
about to turn 40.
uh i meet up with pat he shows up on a
freaking helicopter
i'm telling people about the interview
with kobe bryant
and boom three days later kobe bryant
dies
in a tragic helicopter accident so my
brain my whole mentality was completely
messed up
the dust settled a couple weeks went by
i revisit things with pat
and he says come on man let's go i'm
waiting on you move out to dallas
i was like oh damn uh let's do this
so what end up what ends up happening is
i moved from miami to dallas to be a
part
of what pat is building right here
with valuetainment so i moved to dallas
i don't know anybody in dallas i barely
know anybody on valuetainment other than
pat
and mario and i said screw it let me go
for what i want to do
so i moved to uh to dallas to be a part
of valuetainment
and here's the next thing that i learned
kobe bryant had it and patrick bet david
has it
and that is known as the mamba mentality
now if you're not familiar with the
mamba mentality that is the term
or the slogan that basically kobe used
to completely live his entire life
he completely lived his life by this
mamba mentality this intense
focus that he had in everything that he
was doing
his intense focus that he brought in his
preparation
and onto his gains obviously and that's
why he's one of the greatest basketball
players
to ever live and we'll touch on the
legacy that he left
of why i think he was going to be one of
the best businessmen
to ever live but let's focus on mambo
mentality the mamba mentality has
three main components from what i can
understand three main components with
the mamba
mentality component number one is
mindset
the mamba mentality mindset like
where's your brain at with everything
you're doing where's your vision where's
your focus
are you hyper vigilant in what you want
to accomplish
and is your mindset there to match that
so that's something that i learned being
a part of valuetainment and seeing
patrick
this guy's super successful worth
hundreds of millions of dollars whatever
but he's still grinding like he's a
minimum wage employee
looking to get a pay raise like that's
how
hyper focused and hyper village uh
vigilant
pat's mentality was and that's the same
thing that kobe has
and that's that mamba mindset that's
that mamba
mentality number two
work ethic the work ethic so they say
what separates
the ordinary from the extraordinary is
work ethic and the amount of work
that you're willing to put in most
people are just like
happy they got their nine to five they
clock in they clock it
they clock out peace out they're out
they made their money they're gone
are you working 12-hour days are you
working 15-hour days
are you willing to put in the work kobe
was the first guy that showed up at the
gym
and the last guy to leave that was the
mamba mentality
so that's number two number three in
terms of mamba
mentality is your willingness to be
great
your greatness like how bad do you want
to be great
and and they say that especially with
the mamba mentality in order to be great
you have to focus on one thing like a
lot of people are doing a little bit of
this and a little bit of that
and they're kind of dabbling here and
their of all trades
there's something called the riches are
in the niches
kobe was a basketball player
professional basketball player for 20
years and that was his complete
and only focus so the willingness to be
great so the great philosopher aristotle
once said
we are what we repeatedly do he says
excellence is not an act but a habit
like something that you do every single
day part of the mamba mentality is
trying to get better
every single day in what you're trying
to accomplish
so here's what you need to ask yourself
now how are you mommifying
your own life like what are you doing
to have that mamba mentality remember
the three things the mindset
number two the work ethic and number
three the willingness
to be great to achieve greatness so how
are you mommifying your own life
what's your mindset at right what's your
level of work ethic
how great do you want to be that's what
i take
from the mamba mentality moving right
along let's now leave
off on legacy let's talk about the
legacy that kobe bryant left
into this world kobe bryant once said
you have to ask yourself
you have to figure out what gets you up
and going in the morning and what keeps
you up at night
and once you find the answer to that you
have to stay true
to that let me say that one more time
kobe bryant asked
what is it that gets you going in the
morning and what is it that keeps you up
at night and once you find the answer to
that
that my friends is what you need to stay
true to
so luckily for me i found
what my passion was i found what my
legacy was going to be i'm wearing it
right here baby
this is my mamba mentality i put this
shirt on i'm feeling damn good
about what i'm doing so my question to
you is
do you know what you want your legacy to
be do you know
what gets you going in the morning what
keeps you up at night and are you
staying
true to that you know speaking of legacy
kobe bryant's left us right like our
legacy is when
our body ceases to exist but our
greatness
lives up so i'm so thankful
for what kobe has given us because
yes he was one of the best basketball
players ever and i also have no
doubt that he would have been one of the
best business people and entrepreneurs
ever but now what he's enabled in all of
us is to say
damn like this can all get taken in an
instant let me answer some
of these questions that are super
important
to understand while i'm alive what am i
passionate about
what gets me up in the morning what
keeps me up at night am i staying true
to that
and am i leaving the legacy that i
want to leave it's all about legacy so i
started this entire episode
with understanding personal finance what
is
your chilling like what would you do
with your free time if you had millions
in the bank
like retirement is an antiquated term
nobody just
retires and does nothing people want to
travel people want to
give back people want to pursue a
passion but the greats want to leave a
legacy
so what do you want your legacy to be
and i'm thankful
that kobe bryant's legacy was inspiring
people like me to even do an episode
like this
to help people like you so i hope you
appreciated this
i hope you're answering some of these
questions about what you're chilling is
and what you want your legacy to be i
know
valuetainment off the record i'm not
confirming or denying but we are here
in south florida these days so you can
wait for an announcement
for that but there should be some more
beaches in our
in our time horizon but what do you want
your legacy to be
and i hope you appreciated this episode
and i'm thankful that kobe bryant
inspired this so if you want to check
out more information on what i talk
about on the six principles of wealth
to figure out what your chilling is and
the first five principles to get you
there
check out this episode that we'll put
right here called the six principles of
wealth
how to win the money game if you have
not subscribed
to valuetainment economics yo do so
below and give that
like button a little tap tap taparoo if
you will
so last but not least make sure you're
doing what you need to do
to ensure that you're leaving a legacy
and as always save that
money all we talk is money all we talk
is